en este vídeo veremos un ejemplo de una
reacción que usa el principio de leche
atelier lo que haremos es aplicar el
principio de leche atelier para analizar
algunos cambios que podrían ocurrir si
perturbamos el equilibrio de esta
reacción y aquí me refiero si digo que
esta reacción se encuentra en equilibrio
bueno aquí tenemos una reacción
reversible la reacción directa o hacia
la derecha tiene una constante de
velocidad y la reacción inversa o hacia
la izquierda
también tiene una constante de velocidad
entonces cuando la reacción se encuentra
en un equilibrio dinámico estas
velocidades son iguales y por lo tanto
todas las concentraciones se mantendrán
constantes entonces lo primero que vamos
a hacer es ver qué pasa cuando agregamos
un poco de dióxido de carbono gaseoso
si agregamos dióxido de carbono la
concentración de este gas aumentará o
también lo podemos ver como que la
presión parcial aumenta y el principio
de leche atelier nos dice que si tenemos
una reacción que se encuentra al
equilibrio y luego la desequilibramos
agregando más co2
la reacción cambiará la dirección para
intentar minimizar el efecto de ese
cambio así que se favorecerá la reacción
inversa
entonces si agregamos co2 lo que ocurre
es que se favorece en los reactivos
otra forma en que podemos verlo es
analizando la constante de equilibrio
para esta reacción vamos a escribir
nuestra constante de equilibrio que esta
es una cama yus q la
la escribiré así para que se vea que es
mayúscula y podemos escribir la de dos
formas primero podemos escribirla en
términos de la concentración molar
entonces si escribimos casi esto es
igual a la concentración del producto
que es el co2 gaseoso
y nada más porque cuando escribimos casi
escribimos las concentraciones de gases
y de soluciones pero no se toman en
cuenta los sólidos así que nuestra casa
es simplemente igual a la concentración
de co2 al equilibrio voy a escribir eco
aquí para recalcar que es la
concentración al equilibrio y otra forma
en que podemos escribir la constante de
equilibrio es en términos de presiones
parciales entonces aquí tenemos nuestra
cama muscular pero ahora con una p como
subíndice eso significa que en lugar de
concentración es ahora para los gases
todo estará en términos de presión
parcial entonces aquí tenemos la presión
parcial de co2 y nuevamente eso es todo
porque todo lo demás es sólido y por eso
no se toman en cuenta para la expresión
de equilibrio
ahora vamos a pensar en qué pasaría si
incrementamos incrementamos el volumen
del contenedor
miren si usamos la ley de los gases
ideales la presión parcial del co2 es
igual a los moles de co2 por rt entre el
volumen igualmente podemos escribir la
concentración molar en términos de moles
entre volumen si incrementamos el
volumen del contenedor entonces como el
volumen se encuentra en el denominador
al incrementar el volumen la presión
disminuye así que la presión parcial de
co2 disminuye y ya no nos encontramos al
equilibrio lo mismo para la
concentración como nuestra perturbación
disminuye la concentración de dióxido de
carbono el principio de lecha tellier
nos dice que nuestra reacción tratará de
contrarrestar ese cambio tratará de
regresar al equilibrio y de recuperar la
concentración de co2 por lo tanto la
reacción se favorece
hacia los productos nuestra reacción
favorecerá a los productos para tratar
de recuperar los moles de co2 y así
regresar a la concentración de co2 al
equilibrio y la presión parcial al
equilibrio ok ahora el tercer cambio que
vamos a analizar es qué pasaría si
agregamos gas argón vamos a ver el argón
es un gas inerte no esperaríamos que
reaccione con algo así que una cosa que
puede ocurrir es que si agregamos argón
eso aumentará la presión total del
contenedor entonces aumenta la presión
total pero eso no nos dice qué pasa con
el equilibrio regresemos a nuestras
expresiones de equilibrio café y café
miren la presión parcial de café solo
depende de los moles de co2 y del
volumen y como no cambiamos los moles de
co2 y tampoco cambiamos el volumen aún
cuando la presión total aumenta
y un parcial de 0 2 permanece igual
igual eso significa que no perturba mos
el equilibrio de la reacción y por lo
tanto como no perturbamos el equilibrio
no habrá ningún cambio todavía nos
encontramos al equilibrio
las concentraciones se mantienen iguales
pero ahora qué pasa si agregamos un poco
de carbonato de calcio que es nuestro
reactivo y además es un sólido bueno
como nuestras expresiones de equilibrio
están determinadas por las
concentraciones de co2 al agregar más
carbonato de calcio que es un sólido eso
no va a perturbar el equilibrio de la
reacción porque nuestra reacción seguirá
en equilibrio
y no habrá ningún cambio en las
concentraciones ok y vamos a analizar un
caso más pensemos en qué pasaría si
agregamos un catalizador digamos que
queremos acelerar un poco esta reacción
y podemos visualizar lo que pasa cuando
agregamos el catalizador usando un
diagrama de energía aquí tenemos un
diagrama de energía en donde tenemos a
la energía en el eje y y estamos
buscando la diferencia de energía entre
los reactivos y los productos ahorita
solo invente estas energías relativas
pero en la forma en que dibuje esto
podemos ver que nuestro producto tiene
menor energía que el reactivo y la
velocidad directa
cate que tenemos aquí arriba está
determinada por el tamaño de esta
barrera de energía de activación que
existe entre nuestro reactivo y el
estado de transición mientras que la
velocidad inversa
y está determinada por el tamaño de esta
barrera de energía así que es la
diferencia de energía entre el producto
y el estado de transición entonces si
agregamos un catalizador a nuestra
reacción lo que sucede es que disminuye
la energía de activación de la reacción
y eso significa que tenemos una barrera
de energía más pequeña para la reacción
directa entonces nuestra reacción
directa será más rápida pero también va
a disminuir la velocidad de la reacción
inversa así que acá inversa o acá y
también acelera entonces como aceleramos
la velocidad tanto de la reacción
directa como de la inversa al agregar un
catalizador tampoco perturbamos el
equilibrio de la reacción así que
agregar un catalizador no cambia las
concentraciones ok y bueno yo creo que
lo más importante a recordar de este
problema bueno al menos las cosas que yo
considero más importantes son que al
agregar un gas inerte
aumentará la presión total pero no
cambiará ninguna de las presiones
parciales porque la reacción permanecerá
en equilibrio y lo mismo ocurre con
sólidos y catalizadores entonces para
todas estas tres cosas gases inertes
sólidos y catalizadores el equilibrio de
la reacción no cambia